no hay signos de que esté remitiendo el
último rebrote de coronavirus en china
que ha sido calificado por la prensa
oficial como el peor desde que la
pandemia surgiera en enero de 2020 en
luján la comisión nacional de salud ha
informado hoy de 55 nuevos casos lo que
eleva el saldo de julio a 328 es decir
más que el total de los últimos cinco
meses haya 26 ciudades afectadas por el
rebrote en provincias tan alejadas como
liaoning en el norte guandong en el sur
o sichuan en el centro hoy se han
identificado además los primeros casos
en jane joe la ciudad que todavía se
está recuperando de las últimas lluvias
caídas en los últimos 60 años y que la
semana pasada dejaron 99 muertos también
se han identificado casos en change in
la mega ciudad del interior y en fujián
la provincia costera cercana a taiwán
china está disfrutando de algo parecido
a la vieja normalidad desde hace más de
un año y sofocando todos los rebrotes
sin mayores problemas la virulencia del
presente se debe a que detrás está la
nueva variante del está mucho más
yo sé que las anteriores